[Musique]
au curling classique il faut quatre
joueurs pour avoir la stratégie en tête
le compas dans l'oeil et les ballets
bien en bas
dans la nouvelle épreuve le double mixte
il faut couvrir tous les aspects à 2
comment y arriver
démonstration avec emilie et robert
desjardins le coeur ligne à la fois
sport de glace est partie d'échecs
la stratégie côtoient l'effort physique
dans chaque équipe il faut partager les
tâches pour mettre à profit les atouts
de chacun premier atout la finesse il
faut placer ses pions pour contrôler
l'échiquier
en double mixte chaque manche débute
avec une pierre à contourner pour
atteindre la cible
il faut donc viser un peu à côté de
l'obstacle au départ la pierre swing
ligne droite mais à mesure qu'elle
ralentit la friction en demande son
emprise
la trajectoire se met alors à courber
sous l'effet de la rotation de la pierre
si le lancer n'est pas parfait
on peut en partie corrigé le tir grâce
au balayage
l'objectif réchauffer la glace pour la
rendre plus licence pour être efficace
l'athlète se place au dessus du ballet
transfert un maximum de poids et frappe
jusqu'à 5 go par seconde selon le poids
de l'athlète sa force ou sa technique de
balayage la température de la glace
plutôt augmenté d'un demi à deux degrés
celsius
en début trajectoire on se contente de
quelques coups de balai à la proche de
la cible
mais chris active des ballets aussi car
il est plus facile d'évaluer les
corrections à apporter
quand les pierres s'accumulent le jeu se
corse lors des deux derniers lancers
le règlement permet de passer à
l'attaqué en augmentant la puissance des
lancers
pour y arriver l'athlète mise tout sur
sa force et sa masse contribue aussi à
amplifier sa glissade vers l'avant il
peut donner à la pierre jusqu'à deux
fois plus de vitesse une énergie dont
elle aura bien besoin
lapierre fait près de 20 kg elle est
taillée dans un granit très dense
lors d'un impact elle cross mais presque
toute son énergie à notre pierre seel en
vrac plusieurs sa force d'impact diminue
avec chaque collision
certaines situations sont de véritables
casse têtes qui exige à la fois
puissance des précisions
[Musique]
et donne parfois lieu à des finales
spectaculaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]